what did you think of the fights which
ones joey benavidez and a tough one
poor joey well one guy's on his way up
the other guy's
you know just a bummer vigorito
brazilian monster just such a bummer
yeah
it's good fights this weekend darren
till
whitaker whitaker that's going to be
verdum
goffstein is fighting heavyweight now
yep which i think is a very good move me
too
also little nog shogun
i don't want to see great legends take
damage i i just don't like it
i just don't i mean at least at least
it's at least i'm not finding young guys
this is not some young [ __ ] monsters
thank god i would have restrictions on
that
i really would like if you're if you're
a little nogger or
nog well if you want to talk but you
know shogun they're little nog they
don't get into it just to fight old
heads they want to fight for a title so
because then to get there you've got
warriors yeah you have to protect them
from themselves as we know the ufc's
never
come on dude they've never done that
look at bj penn guffan could be the
heavyweight champion
he could because uh dc and steepe the
winner of that
they're both who doesn't matter they're
both going to retire are they both going
to retire yeah i think they're both done
i hope they both do yeah
so they have nothing to prove they're
incredible i mean i know dc's done for
sure i don't know stipe gustafson
ngano that's a great fight guessing
curtis blades guthrie and derrick lewis
there's so much fun fighting that's a
handful
good match he's would you say he's the
best striker in the um
in the uh heavyweight division no
alistar over here
even now oh yeah he hasn't he hasn't
he's experienced he's not slower he's
not i mean he might be but as far as
technically like fundamentals alex rover
is the best
striker in heavyweight history k1
champion
rosen strokes no punk you look at his
background right
jds is no punk no jds has taken so much
damage though
you know dustin's not young dude he's
taking a lot how old is him
i don't know but he's hurt he's retired
before too yeah yeah he always had a
precarious
well he's always been like right there
he's been right there he's a huge he's a
superstar in sweden right superstar
billboard's everywhere about six six oh
he's ever been at six sex
yeah dwarf me i saw him with his [ __ ]
shoes off
oh he dwelt backstage for me jesus he's
33.
he's 33 mma 33. some wars with dc
jon jones a lot rumble johnson like he's
had some tough goes man
yes he is um whitaker till
great fight i got whitaker
oh why is that i mean he's the underdog
but slight
slight it's basically evil it's
interesting it's interesting
i'm sorry till's the only tells you i'm
sorry for a second i thought you picked
kill
no i got i got whitaker yeah he's the
slight favorite probably hits a little
harder
more explosive yep i don't know if he
hits harder he's more explosive
till's a monster dude i can't believe
tilly's fight 170.
well when he stepped into the ring
against huge uh uh donald cerrone
apparently he was 204 pounds
oh yeah monster what's nuts how he can
lose that weight
whitaker took some time off he's had
some injuries you know he also went
through [ __ ] two wars with
romero
yeah that's right that's heavy [ __ ]
that's like we always say like you have
a certain number of rounds in you and
then remember tale though his last fight
was against kelvin gaslamin when i think
split decision was a war man yeah it was
a war and before that he lost him
in woodley and woodley woodley did he
get knocked out or he got you got
submitted
yeah that's right basically knocked down
then submitted
a tough go great fight though
who else is fighting on that card that's
about i mean for for this that's about
it let me listen to the bane
you know your money's on whitaker i'm
not i wouldn't put money on the fight
we're not bet on this fight too close to
a fight love both guys too much
wouldn't bet on it way too you don't who
knows what's gonna happen i'm gonna tell
you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected